[Music]
and kylosaurs were one of the most
remarkable of dinosaurs perhaps the most
heavily armored of any animal that the
world has ever seen
thank you
they're so odd I think they're one of
the most bizarre animals when you look
at the proportions of their bodies there
are questions around how they even
walked how they moved
they had spikes extending from their
shoulder regions a bony covering of
armor all over their heads
some of them even had bony eyelids
one feature more than all the others
separates them from any animal alive
today
their extraordinary Tale
so what was it for
some ankylosaurs have very peculiar
Tails where they take the armor on other
parts of the body and elaborate it into
what we call a trail Club
these are two huge lumps of armor that
are fused to the very last few vertebrae
within the tail and form this structure
a little bit like a hammer
when they were first discovered they
were interpreted as a weapon of some
kind
this one belonged to a kind of
ankylosaur known as an odontosaur
but what makes us think that this was
ever wielded like a club
[Music]
comparing ankylosaurs with animals alive
today suggests that it was
on numerous occasions within the history
of life animals have evolved specialized
structures that only function in combat
these are often quite large and unusual
structures like the horns of rhinos the
antlers of deer
the horns of antelope
powerful muscles and reinforced bone
allow them to use these structures as
weapons
[Music]
fossils show in kylosaur Tails had
similar adaptations
there's evidence on the pelvis for
muscles that extended down the tail and
that would have attached to the handle
of this tail Club
it's very stiff it's different by lots
of bony rods that run along the length
of the tail that would have had a lot of
force behind it when it was swung from
side to side some paleontologists have
calculated that could be swung with
enough Force to devastate a car
it could have made a formidable weapon
to defend itself against enemies
but now scientists are asking a new
question
[Music]
in theory ankylosaur Tails would have
been able to break the legs of predators
but
it's possible that they were also using
their tail clubs for fighting a rival
for a mate or to be the the leader of
the pack
[Music]
in fact the most recent study from 2022
reveals injuries among alkylosaurs that
proved they used their clubs for
fighting each other
We Are One Step Closer to fully
understanding this bizarre looking
dinosaur
[Music]